what is financial freedom without
[Music]
Health what's happening my name is
Samuel Leeds I've just arrived in Spain
CPE and I'm going to be spending 3 days
on my fitness goals in the last 12
months I've lost five stone in weight
I've been climbing up mountains I've
been doing boxing fights and now I'm
ready for my next big goal so I'm going
to be with my personal trainer we're
going to be doing some crazy fitness
challenges and exercises and I thought
I'd share a little bit of a vlog of the
thing I do when I'm on my 3-day Retreats
enjoy so are you ready for a hard 3 days
physically I'm interested in what he's
going to be like what is he like is he
hardcore I thought you going to say
horrible will push
you literally 100% to your
max you're scared aren't you of this I'm
a little bit scared
waiting for Samuel and his brother
Russell to arrive now Samuel's been here
once before but Russell first time
training in Spain looking forward to
seeing him but I'm kind of feel a little
bit bad for the guy don't think he
realizes is quite what he's in
for yes boys finally what's I see a big
guy can freaking lean man where's your
belly gone you know bro nice to meet you
brother how you doing what have you been
doing training wise up till now do you
kind of do similar thing to Samuel or
you what what's you think not similar at
all so I've been doing since for about
year a lot cardio right and then maybe 3
4 weeks ago I started doing weight
training now he wants to get he's lost a
lot of weight like I have you've lost
like four stone I've lost four stone now
he wants to get a bit a bit bit of
muscle right so so you boys obviously
have done crazy things in business how
how did you both end up that out of
shape and then why why now why are you
now doing this this whole screw you
Steve how' you end up so broke
[Music]
f
let's get you measured up big
boy nice right and now we're going do
the chest hands
up all right hands down just come around
a
pick
okay let me do that again stomach is
massively gone down wicked
[Music]
cool
that's what happens when you don't pay
Steve to be your coach that's what
happens I think just started
bro give him 3 months
[Music]
man that's it come on
right come on push push push come on bro
you had that man come on all the way up
right you need to get focused you need
to get a bit more PES up right you need
to give it that freaking boast mode
right so have you got something you can
think about to get yourself PES
up um no all
right okay okay let's
go keep going keep going come on come on
come on push push push push yes yeah man
come on come on son good boy well done
come
on nice come on man I'm happy oh is
that so so what you slap him right cuz I
knew a th% that he could lift that
weight unfortunately he psyched himself
out before he did it so he went into it
and he was kind of feeling a bit psyed
up but you could tell that he wasn't
really focused so I needed to put him
into beast mode gave me slap fired up
the adrenals and he freaking did it so
it works and sometimes unfortunately
especially when it's a one rep max
you've got to go into that kind of dark
place where you're really pushing to the
next level and when someone whacks you
on the back you're literally going to
fight or fly and uh yeah job
done come on get
excited o you almost
[Music]
set go tell the whole
world about to set it up when we go co
Coast party every
day on the way tell me where to
go land
[Music]
here
come
on when I'm walking up a mountain like
that it's the one place I feel
completely distressed relaxed I think
it's because all you can think about is
your next step there's something
metaphorical about climbing the mountain
isn't there obviously we've seen your
transformation you're freaking killing
it really excited to get your bra on
board as well he's going to kill it as
well but I reckon we should take you to
the next level now so obviously at the
time we started you had a boxing match
you're preparing for which you did
amazingly with you got your Fitness up
to the next level but unfortunately
because of that we got you lean but we
didn't get you Mega lean so I think look
you do a lot of photo shoots you do a
lot of Social Media stuff you're a very
visible public figure why don't we take
your body to the ultimate level and we
do a natural bodybuilding show it's
interesting you'd be up for it
yeah that's really interesting i' to be
honest I've never even I've never even
considered anything like that let's
let's compare it to your business right
you guys make many million a year in
your property business what what if I
said to you why don't you just stop at
wait making 1 million a more a year it's
more than most people would ever dream
of so technically by most people's
standards even they laughing at you even
they laughing exactly but most people's
standards you've done well but you know
it's not the best you can possibly do
yeah why would you not want to take your
body to while young I'm up for it in
principle I am up for it nice when would
it be it's going to be really hard
though yeah getting in that type of
shape there's a big difference between
looking fit for a normal person looking
fit to be in a competition a crowds come
to look at you what was it the JFK
famous you said about it was that that
that saying we do it not not because
it's easy but because it's hard or
something like that going to the Moon
yeah yeah so
yeah we go let's get back man before we
get do y cool
[Music]
bro
biggest lessons for me this week
reinforce some of the stuff that I
already knew and already practiced in
the business world but I think getting
uncomfortable in every Avenue of life
whether that's be doing bodybuilding
climbing up a mountain pushing yourself
physically your business growing your
business just constantly getting
uncomfortable is how you grow second
thing is always have goals you know
maintaining is boring you don't get rich
and then say now I'm going to just try
and maintain it you get rich and then
you push into the next goal push into
the next goal and in Fitness and
everything is the same the third thing
is who you're around is who you become
there's no way if I wasn't in this
environment with these guys I would have
been able to get my personal best on my
on my bench press there's no way I would
have been able to climb up that mountain
at the speed that we did it we were
running part of it there's no way I
would have been able to do that if I
wasn't around good people so get around
good people appreciate you
brother I'm glad that you were with me
as well my man good to see you if you
more Vlogs subscribe alth generally
speaking it's going to be all around
property how you can make money how you
can become financially independent
through property investment maybe we'll
be doing some cool stuff here in Spain
absolutely man we got our eyes over all
kinds of stuff see you next
[Music]
time
bye